vous voulez sentir peut-être ça sent bon
santé allez-y dites moi vous avez gagné
maintenant le romarin sas ans a connu
pour certains beaucoup moins pour
d'autres plantes aromatiques fruits et
légumes n'ont désormais presque plus de
secret pour ces jeunes guyancourt toi
j'ai appris le pomelo ça va pas du tout
ce que c'était en fait c'est un mélange
d'orange de pamplemousse ces exercices
ça permettait de comprendre le milieu
des légumes elle ça participe à la
découverte du goût et donc c'est
compléter un peu l'éducation du goût des
enfants ça participe à leur faire
découvrir de nouveaux produits
alimentaires alors montré les fruits de
saison leur expliquer ce qu'était d'une
l'hygiène alimentaire bien se nourrir
pourquoi c'est important
un atelier organisé par la ville au
lycée d'hôtellerie et de tourisme
les enfants de ces centres de loisirs au
même pu goûter la cuisine des élèves
au menu tomates macédoine et poulet
gratin dauphinois surtout ce que j'adore
c'est la nourriture je connaissais pas
du tout mais en fait c'est un très bon
endroit ils font de la bonne nourriture
et j'adore je pense que ce n'est pas
anodin de les faire venir découvrir les
produits dans un lycée hôtelier de faire
un repas dans un lycée hôtelier ils sont
servis par des élèves qui sont tous très
bien habillés en tenues ils voient des
belles personnes peut être que chez
certains ça pourrait donner un ca
pourrait déclencher des envies des
futures vocations
la fête du goût se poursuit dans la
commune jusqu'à la fin de l'année des
ateliers culinaires seront prochainement
organisées au vélodrome nationale